today
僕は日本とアフリカなど世界中の子どもたちをダンスとインターネット中継でつないで
います
今まで22カ国1万5000人以上の子どもたちにダンスを教えて
そのうち3千人以上の子どもたちをつないできました
ただなかなか想像がつかないと思うのでまずは写真を見て頂ければと思います
この写真はウガンダエチオピア
日本の子ども達です
日本とウガンダ日本とエチオピアなど中継れつないで一緒にダンス踊るんです
日本とアフリカの子どもをつなぐことが多いのですがベトナムやカンボジアなどアジア
の国々の子供たちも繋いでいます
一緒にダンスを踊ることで国や文化や言語の違いを超えてとっても仲良くなるんです
みんな楽しそうですよね
僕が今日みなさんにお伝えしたいメッセージは一つだけです
それは
やりたい事を口に出そうということです
そんなの恥ずかしいとか口に出したところで何が変わるんだという人もいるかもしれ
ません
でもやりたいことを口に出したら僕の人生は大きく変わりました
今日はそんなお話をしたいと思います
これはあっはい
他の写真なんですけどね
はいこれは小学生時代高校生時代大学生時代の僕の写真です
変化がありますかねはい
今は全国海外を飛び回っているので活動的な人だと思われることが多いのですが
もともとは全然行動力がなかったしやりたいことに全然チャレンジできない人でした
自分に自信がなかったしコンプレックスだらけだったんです
だからこの写真に写ってる頃の僕たちはすごい内気な頃の僕です
もともと兄と比較してずっと劣等感を抱えていました
僕はにより成績も低かったし兄が通っていた学校にも落ちて通えなかったし
スポーツもダメでした
ダンスもありの影響で始めました
あに通っていたからかっこいいなと思って僕も高校生の時にダンスを始めました
大学に入ってもダンス漬けの毎日
熱中するものがあっても相変わらず自分に自信はありませんでした
周りとの人間関係もうまくいかず高校生の時にいじめられていた経験から周りの人全然
信用することができませんでした
人と接するのが本当に怖かったんです
ただ毎日同じ場所でダンスの練習をしていくうちに段々とこう仲良くなってきて
騙されてもいいからもっと仲良くなりたいなそんなお気持ちが芽生えてきて少しずつ
少しずつ変わっていくことができました
また大学の先輩の紹介もあって
キッズダンス教室でダンスの講師もしました
とっても楽しかったです
そんなダンス付の大学生活を送っていました
そんな大学生活だったんですが漠然とした夢も持っていました
世界一周がしたかったんです
広い世界を見てみたいなと思っていたし何か大きなことをしたい
そんな風に思って世界一緒に憧れていたんですが大学生の時はいけませんでした
怖かったんです
僕が世界一になって無理だーっていうふうに思っていた理由は3つあります
まずは英語ができないと思っていたこと
大学の学年で僕はビリーの成績でした
本当に英語ができなかったんです英語がとにかく強くって
海外の人とコミュニケーションをとるなんて無理だそんな風に思ってました
そして2つめはお腹が弱いこと
本当の高いファインですけどお腹が弱い僕が海外の過酷な環境で過ごすなんてできない
そんな風に思ってました
そして3つ目は海外が強い海外行くの怖いな
そんな風に思っていました
もともと何か新しいことにチャレンジをしたことがなかった僕はそもそも何か新しい
ことに挑戦すること自体に恐怖を感じていました
そんな僕は世界一周に憧れしたけど行けず
留学にも憧れしたけど行けず大学生活をそのまま終えて会社に就職し働き始めました
会社員になって施工社会人として働き始めてからも学生時代の時にダンスをしていてい
た生徒やその保護者の人たちから
またダンスを教えてくださいそんな風に言われてたんですけどやりたいけど忙しいので
出来ません
そんな風に言って断っていました
でも忙しいっていうのはただの言い訳だったんですね
本心としてはすごい怖かったんです
僕はこう何か自分で人を集めて会を実施するということを一切やったことがなかったの
で自信がありませんでした
すごい怖かったんです
ただ社会人4年目のときに転機が訪れました
たまたま参加した教育関係の交流会でした
その時についポロッと言ってしまったんです
ダンスを教えたいと思ってるんですけどねそんな風に言ってしまったんです
教育に関心のある人って熱い人が多いんですよ
みんなキラーンていこう目が輝いてですねやってみたらいいじゃやってみないよそんな
風に背中押されました
いやない理由がないじゃん言われました
公民館借りたらいいし週末にちょっと時間作ったらいいし声をかけてくれている子ども
たちとか保護者の人に手伝ってもらったらいいじゃん一回やってみなよ
そんな風にもぐいぐいぐいぐい背中おしゃれました
そして僕は
会社員として働きながら週末にボランティアでまた子どもたちに男装生はじめました
20人以上の子どもたちが集まってくれてレッスンは大成功でした
本当に幸せな体験でした
やりたいことを口に出していろんな人が手伝ってくれて一緒にハッピーな歯をつくる
ことができるんだ
そんなふうに思えた初めての経験でした
人からしたら小さなことかもしれないですけど僕にとっては大きな経験でした
やりたいことってできるんだやりたいことを先延ばしするのやめよう
そんな風に思いました
もうレッスンが終わって帰りの電車でも胸の内ががすごいフレイてるんですねはなんて
幸せなんだろう
やりたいことってできるんだそんな風に思いました
そして家に帰ると家の壁には学生時代の頃に書いた
世界史するっていう紙が貼ってあったんですね
学生の頃からずっと張ってたんですよ
世界一周って一生のうちいつかできたらいいなと思ってたけどこれって今すぐできるん
だ
そんな風に思いました
もう迷いはありませんでした
4年間働いた会社を辞めて夢だった世界一周に出発しました
大好きだったダンスをせながら世界中を回ることにしたんです
旅前も旅中もやりたいことを口に出したら素敵な例がたくさんありました
僕にとっては初めての海外一人旅が世界主だったんです
だから来た日のこと全然知らなかったんですね
無謀だとか言われるんですけどはいただダンスを西長瀬回収したいんですって
出会う人出会う人に続けて sns で書いたりブログで書いたりしているうちに旅人
を紹介してくれたり
海外で子供に関わっている人を紹介してくれたりしました
英語が本当に怖かったので最初の2カ月間はピリピに留学に行きました
語学留学をしました
この時に学んだのは単語や文法ももちろん大切だけどそれ以上に自分のことを伝えた
いっていう気持ちだったり相手のことを知りたいそういう気持ちが一番大事なんだなと
いうことを知りました
またやりたいことに一歩踏み出すのに出遅れてしまった
そんな風に思っていた僕にフィリピン人の先生は全部最適なタイミングでやってくるん
だよ
だからあなたにとっては今がベストタイミングなんだよ
そんな風に言ってくれました
今もその言葉をすごい大事にしています
ますいざ出発した世界主は本当に素敵な例がたくさんあって
まさしく自分にとってベストなタイミングでした
最初にフィリピンの語学学校に行った時も弾塑性たいんですって色んな人に言ってい
たら
その語学学校の売店のスタッフさんが近所の子供たちを集めてくれてそれで初めての
ダンスレッスンをしました
すごい楽しかったです
アフリカのマラウイでもダンスを教えたいんですって言ったら
村中の人が手伝ってくれて
すごいですよね阿蘇2000人の子どもたちと一緒にダンスフェスティバルを開催し
ました
もうこの学校とか僕はバスで10時間くらい揺られていった村なんですけどお腹いたが
痛くなりながらね行ったんですけどそしたら連の人が歓迎してくれてみんな手伝って
くれました
そんなマロリーの映像があるのでちょっと動画を見てほしいなと思います
[音楽]
んん
tuj 分
[音楽]
bj
ウーファー
アルファ
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
本当に楽しかったです子どもたちもすごい楽しんでくれました
いろんな人が手伝ってくれて感謝までされてしまいました
僕がやりたいと言って始めたことなのにです
国や言葉や文化の違いを超えて世界中に友達が出来ました
もともとほか人が強いと思ってたんですなのに世界生友達ができました
自分の人生がすごい豊かになったなそんなふうに感じました
自分の価値観も世界観も大きく広がりました
ダンスでの交流を通して自分に自信もつきました
みんなそれぞれ自分だけの価値を持っているんだな
そんな風に思うようになりました
2歳のちっちゃい子もおじいちゃんおばあちゃんもみんなかっこいいダンス踊るんです
よね
誰を見てもうわすごいかっこいいなと思ったし
みんなもこう僕のことを素直に認めてくれるんですあー一人一人がその人だけの価値を
持ってるんだ
そんな風に思えるようになりました
そんな風に変化していった僕なんですがもともとは会社員の時にダンスを教えたいと
思ってるんですけどね
そんな風に言ってしまったことから全ては始まりました
世界集を得て自分のような経験をいろんな子どもたちにも経験してほしい
そんな風に思うようになりました子どもたちの可能性や世界も大きく広げたい
世界中の子供たちも友達になってほしいなそんな風に思うようになりました
だから帰国後は自分のダンス教室を始めて日本中いや世界中を飛び回りながら世界中の
子どもたちをダンスとインターネット中継でつなげる活動をしています
今後はいろんな世代の人が集まって一緒に学び合える
そんな地域の場をつくりたいなと思っています
ダンスやインターネットは僕にとってあくまでツールで僕の目的は子どもたちの世界や
可能性を広げたいなぁということであったり自分に自信を持ってもらいたいな
そんなことが目的です
子どもだけに限らずいろんな人の背中を押したいそんな風に思っています
なぜなら僕自身が背中をいっぱいをされたことで
一歩踏み出すことができて自分の人生が大きく変わったからです
強くてもいいんです
怖いけどやりたいことこそ本当にやりたいことなんだと思います
やりたいことからは逃げられません
やり方なんて動き出さなきゃわかりません
僕の場合はやりたいことを口に出したらいろんな人が協力してくれて一緒にハッピーな
歯をつくることができました
もしかしたら反対する人もいるかもしれません
でも自分の人生の責任をとれるのは自分だけです
誰かが自分の責任を取ってくれるわけでありません
だから自分で決断して行動することが大事なんだと思っています
僕の場合は
やりたいことを口に出して一歩踏み出すことができました
もし皆さんが何か新しい一歩を踏み出したい
そんな風に思っていたら
やりたいことをぜひ口に出してみてください
そうすることが
人生が大きく広がる最初の一歩になるんだと思います
そうやってみんなが自分の大好きなことをやっていける世界になったらいいな
そんな風に思っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]